Facebook is basically a public utility
you look at you've got over a billion
people using this service that's that's
not a choice for many people certainly
not choice for a lot of teenagers it's
kind of social suicide to not be a part
of that hey what's up i'm paul dietrich
with recent TV and today we're talking
with filmmaker cullen Hoback he's a
filmmaker who's made a new movie called
terms and conditions may apply about
digital privacy Cohen thanks for joining
us happy yeah kind of beer you probably
have the best timing for releasing a
film about privacy especially about
digital privacy with the the leaks from
Edward Snowden coming out in the
Guardian when did you decide to make the
movie why did you decide to make movie
in the first place well I started work
in the film over two years ago and it
was basically done about six months
before any of the Snowden revelations
came out and I've since modified it just
the very end to at least address what's
happened but the reason I started making
film what I was trying to figure out was
what what is the impact of all of this
new technology and it really it wasn't
until I changed the name of the film to
terms and conditions may apply which I
did initially is a metaphor that I said
hold my god like look it's actually the
the terms and conditions that's what's
changed everything in our digital lives
has this contract associated with it and
if you look at books before or TV you
didn't have to sign some kind of
agreement in order to be able to use
those things to read a book but if you
use a kindle or you watch hulu there's
this lengthy contract that comes with it
what was the big thing that changed
everything moved into ones and zeros and
ones and zeros can be tracked and traced
so as we moved it into the late 90s in
the early aughts or whatever you want to
call them we suddenly had everything
that was once physical digitized and
that's the magic of course the digital
universe is that it can all be tracked
it can be followed and unless you put
privacy safeguards in place it can be
highly monitored but we don't have to
use these programs that use ones and
zeros we don't have to use you know
Facebook we don't have to use doing it
well we don't have to I mean at this
point i would say that facebook is
basically a public utility you look
you've got over a billion people using
this service that's that's not a choice
for many people certainly not choice for
a lot of teenagers it's kind of social
suicide to not be a part of that you can
be rebel but I I don't know so at this
point it's hard to say that that opting
out is completely an option this new law
that I signed today will allow
surveillance of all communications used
by terrorists including emails the
internet and cell phones the Patriot Act
is they may be a central character and
you're in your film can you talk about
the patriot act and how it changed
google's privacy policy before and after
911 well what i do in the film ie I go
back and I look at this independent
archive service the Wayback Machine and
I I compare google's privacy policy from
before nine eleven and then after nine
eleven and there were significant
changes the thing is those changes are
only apparent if you use the time
machine they're not apparent if you go
to google's archive service in fact what
Google has done is they've covered up
their original privacy policy you can't
find it on their archives page and it's
hard to know exactly why but I can
surmise why because the one that they
are not showing the privacy policy that
they are not putting on their page
basically says that users are considered
anonymous that they will not share your
data unless you've expressly given them
permission to and then after nine eleven
this changed and and the policy grows
and it talks about all of the different
ways in which data can be shared the
question of your if you will information
being retained by Google is not really
at this point at Google decision it's
really a political or public policy
decision enforced by different
governments in different ways what if
privacy policies weren't about
protecting privacy at all but rather
taking it away one of my favorite
moments in the film is when you go and
meet with a man who had typed into
Google how to kill my wife multiple
times and you found out something when
you went to go meet him well yeah I mean
these so al had released this anonymized
search history and everybody on the
internet who had looked at
this series of searches was convinced
this guy was murder it was like how to
kill my wife wife kill it decapitated
bodies and then like in the middle he
searches for steak and cheese but this
is this is the list and uh so I go over
to this gentleman's house and I show him
this list of things and I asked him you
know have you searched for these things
before he goes down the list he's like
yeah I have searched for every single
one of these including steak and cheese
and watching pilgrim oh my god this
guy's a murderer and then you realize I
asked well what were you doing I'm a
writer on cold case it was a writer on a
TV show a crime a crime drama so of
course that's why he was looking for
this stuff his wife pops out into it's a
cute scene but what this really shows is
that context is so important because
when you look at these searches outside
of what he was doing you can assign him
as a murderer but when you look at them
within context ago of course he was
writing a screenplay so this is the
problem with these systems on the whole
is that I think they're very good at
limiting journalism monitoring
protesters I think they're much worse at
stopping terrorists attacks because
they're not plotting things on Facebook
is there some sort of relationship
between government and and these big
data companies that is a is a hand
holding relationship is that a I don't
know what it is it's it's it's a cozy
relationship where they're both getting
a lot out of it right it's not like the
government and these companies got
together and said yeah let's let you
know it was more like mutually
beneficial so you have the company's
making a fortune and off of our data and
then you have the government getting
something that it's wanted for a very
long time which is this sort of
unprecedented access to all of the
information of all of its citizens but
Facebook can't put you in jail it can't
give you the death penalty at cancer no
not yet yeah facebook is going to give
you the death penalty but I mean they
don't have the power to do those sorts
of things but the government does right
right I mean that's the that's the
challenge here is because we soon as you
hand over your information to a third
party they can give it to the government
and the government can
I decide what they want to do with that
information the most gripping part of
the whole documentary is you confronting
Mark Zuckerberg outside of his home with
wearing a google glass and ended
following him with a camera why did you
decide to do it what did you get from it
what did you hope to get from this
interaction I had tried for four months
to get through to anyone at Facebook i
just wanted to discuss the privacy
practices of their company it didn't
need to be with Mark Zuckerberg and I'd
sent multiple emails the only email
address that they allow you to send
anything to and I got limited to no
response so i went into their office and
I said hey is there somebody here that
maybe I can talk to about this stuff and
they said send says it's an email they
don't even have a phone number you can
call they will take all of the phone
numbers from your phone but they don't
even have a phone number so there's this
real problem with transparency it's
one-sided transparency they want you to
be transparent they're not transparent
at all so I go to Mark Zuckerberg house
to really sort of show the hypocrisy of
this situation and I I approached him on
his way to work and I have spy glasses
on and a couple of cameramen and he asks
me at some point please not record him
so we shut off the cameras but I think
the point is that he he needs you he was
wanting privacy too he was asking for
privacy in that moment and it's not
shocking that you know that that was his
response but it gives you he gives you
such a specific smile that you
freeze-frame on in the film why do why
do you freeze frame on that well well we
had turned off the main camera and he
really loosened up and I think we all
experienced in life this is sort of we
can it wait sense that we're being
surveilled we can sense that we're being
watched i think that that was what I was
sensing when I started work on this film
that I couldn't quite put my finger on
it and I think what he reveals in that
moment is that when you stop recording
when you no longer feel surveilled you
can open up and be more yourself
actually and so that's that's what I'm
kind of hitting home when I want to
freeze frame on that there's a lot that
went into being in the place where
are now but I think we're having a
pretty mature conversation as an as a
nation right now about the balance of
privacy versus security and and the
value of the Constitution in
relationship to these systems well thank
you very much Colin ho back for recent
TV I'm Paul teacher